pour parler de cette guerre en Ukraine
nous sommes en ligne avec Joseph en
rotin bonjour merci d'être avec nous sur
FRANCE 24 vous êtes le rédacteur en chef
du magazine défense et sécuritaire
internationale on voyait un ces images
de ce convoi militaire russe qui se
trouve à 25 km de Kiev maintenant
qu'est-ce que cela signifie selon vous
est-ce que l'on peut s'attendre à une
grosse offensive sur la capitale dans
les prochaines heures
alors bonjour oui effectivement on est
manifestement les Russes sont
manifestement dans une phase de monter
en puissance préalable à la sauce sur
Kiev plusieurs questions restent en
suspens la première c'est de savoir si
cette première colonne va être rejointe
par la pénétrer en russe partie de l'axe
Belgorod carquive grosso modo et qui
était déjà bien avancé en
Ukraine voir si finalement la ville va
se faire assiéger avant que que la Saône
ne soit donnée la deuxième question
c'est de savoir si les grandes unités
ukrainiennes qui n'ont pas encore été
réellement engagé au combat vont
profiter si vous voulez de l'opportunité
de cette colonne en mouvement et dont
vulnérable pour opérer des frappes
d'interdiction est-ce que vous le disiez
à la situation est grave aussi à carquif
ou l'armée russe bombarde ça y est le
centre de la ville car qui bombarder
Mario Paul aussi dans l'est de l'Ukraine
qui se retrouve on l'apprend il y a
quelques minutes sans électricité on est
clairement en train d'assister à une
intensification de l'offensive russe
acquief mais aussi par tout ailleurs en
Ukraine oui absolument en fait les
premiers jours ont vu l'armée russe
n'engagée finalement que son premier
échelon et donc il finit avec pas mal de
force si vous voulez qui était en
réserve et qui attendait encore d'être
engagé ce à quoi on assiste
effectivement depuis un peu plus de 24
heures c'est un accroissement des
niveaux général des niveaux généraux de
violence et au-delà de cela également à
l'esquisse d'une stratégie urbaine
par la Russie une des inconnus dans le
conflit étant de savoir comment la
Russie si vous voulez aller
travailler au regard des des villes
alors est-ce qu'elle allait opérer des
sièges et ce qu'elle allait opérer des
pénétrations qui sont a priori quand
même assez coûteux rue par rue bâtiment
par bâtiment ou au contraire est-ce
qu'elle allait opérer une stratégie de
destruction
préalable en fait à l'entrée à l'entrée
dans les villes si on se fie
effectivement avec l'exemple de carquive
et à l'exemple de de Marie-Paule il est
malheureusement probable que des
destructions
soient opérées finalement pour sidérer
la population et faire en sorte
d'obtenir un statut tel que une ville
ouverte ou quelque chose
du genre oui parce que là maintenant on
a vu des
Ukrainiens qui résistaient est-ce que
cela peut continuer longtemps comme cela
face à l'envahisseur russe alors oui
alors ça c'est effectivement à des
opérations militaires majeures il y a
deux types de réactions et cela dépend
essentiellement des gens et de leur et
de leur combinaisons en fait la première
réaction consiste en fait à céder à
éviter à protéger ses familles etc et à
et finalement à se vendre la deuxième la
deuxième réaction et c'est probablement
ce à quoi on assistera dans les
prochains jours c'est le renforcement en
fait de la résistance populaire
ukrainienne qui est déjà très forte à la
base on a vu dans plusieurs villages et
on l'a vu sur plusieurs axes de
pénétration russe et donc la possibilité
finalement on regarde une crème qui fait
quand même plus de 40 millions
d'habitants de se retrouver avec une
guérilla bien bien accrochée
résistant dynamique avec à cela la
question de savoir comment les Russes
qui n'arrivent finalement qu'avec 200
000 personnes pour 41 millions
d'habitants ça fait cela fait beaucoup
ratio ne l'aurait pas ne leur est pas
favorable avoir comment donc les Russes
réagiront par rapport à la résistance de
la population civile avec les risques
bien évidemment de crimes de guerre qui
sont liés Joseph rotin une dernière
question
d'envoyer des
donne
et ses armes vont-elles arriver en
Ukraine selon vous alors comment
essentiellement par la frontière entre
la Pologne et la Roumanie et puis
ensuite la l'Ukraine donc par voie par
voie routière quand a bien ma foi ça ça
dépend c'est à dire que l'Ukraine reçoit
déjà des armements depuis un certain
temps est-ce que ça va changer la donne
alors en soi non mais par contre ça va
contribuer à l'effort à l'effort de
guerre
ukrainien donc ça va particulièrement
les deux avoir évidemment en fonction
des différents types de munitions qui
sont transférés on voit bien qu'il y a
un gros effort qui est fait de la part
des États européens à l'égard de système
antichard notamment
alors qui ne sont pas qu'antichard qui
sont anti blindés d'une manière d'une
manière générale deux systèmes antérien
portables et la portabilité si vous
voulez de ces systèmes permet une
distribution assez large aux unités
territoriales notamment et leur permet
de rentrer dans des logiques de techno
guérilla donc ça peut leur être
effectivement très utile mais ce n'est
que un des facteurs qui sera déterminant
du résultat de cette guerre merci
beaucoup Joseph en rotin merci d'avoir
été avec nous je rappelle que vous êtes
rédacteur en chef du magazine défense et
sécurité intern